and gentlemen this is a casino battle
while one wrestler true the Joker 20
wrestlers have drawn a card to determine
their suit every three minutes a deck of
cards will be shuffled and when their
suit is randomly selected that group of
five individuals will enter the match
after all four suits have joined the
individual who drew the Joker card will
approach the ring as the final
participant elimination occurs when you
are thrown over the top rope and both
feet touch the floor the last remaining
wrestler will be declared the winner and
will compete for the aew Women's
Championship October 2nd on T and T
currently at the club's Shailaja Royale
Liva based Bobby a push a Priscilla
Kelly and nyla rude well the first five
competitors to start off the casino
Battle Royale to determine who will be
one of the two women to fight for the
aew Women's World Championship this fall
October 2nd on TNT such a huge
opportunity for all of these women but
let's not forget who's in that ring
right you got nyla rose she may have
fallen at fighter fest against Rijo but
here's the deal
she has to be the favorite in this match
of that strength that she displayed at
fighter fest was unreal there's also
some threats in that ring as well expand
don't underestimate the the experience
that straining the lineage of Fabia
Pachi an import from triple-a the
multi-time reina de rayna's champion
that's right
along with the librarian herself leave
abates and peter avalon at ringside with
a look at this everybody jumping on nyla
Rose
smart idea here at the start but now the
roaches pushes everyone away unreal
just that is the power that nyla Rose
has that she is able to push away for
individuals at a time like that just
tremendous strength and she goes to
throw leave abates over the top
leave'em maybe the very first
elimination ah just got clocked oh no
Hagin she's hanging upside down both
feet have to touch the floor to be
eliminated what wait what is going on
triple dropkick by the three remaining
competitors no Priscilla Kelly goes
underneath Bobby appache y'all went
through I know we understand that the
rules of this matchup mine ways that
both feet need to touch the floor but
this is taking it a little too far
feet Excalibur yeah Peter Avila putting
some books underneath the feet of Lima
Bates as Priscilla Kelly and Fabio pachi
oh look at that sto by Priscilla Kelly
we have Shailaja Royale laying in some
shoulders in the midsection of nyla Rose
in the corner and Shailaja Royale by the
way winner of the Dusty Rhodes American
Dream Scholarship in fact oh shut up
down over the top just as I was giving
her all the credit it's like the
caster's curse as we say in esports
Excalibur and now Fabia Pachi Club Nidal
Rose taking up Fabia paci
Priscilla Kelly gets caught in a
crossbody this isn't good this is not
good for health favorite harlot
[Applause]
what a spill outside nyla Rose growing
oceans to the wind and throwing
Priscilla Kelly to the wind and now nyla
Rose has the ring to herself and a good
I would say minute and a half before the
next oh not leave abates place with a
book maybe you should have picked up the
art of war instead of Battle Royale
there oh dear
right over the head enough with your
education and now leave abates
eliminated in short order
but Peter apple on the other librarian
goes Peter
Apple on nylon rose with eyes in the
back of her head the negative beat off
to a hot start here at the casino battle
royale already looking good here for
nyla Rose if she keeps this going and he
water run she could put together and
then punch her ticket to that huge
opportunity to fight for the aew women's
championship but now we're gonna have
our next routine coming in it the
diamonds Penelope for chasm the Ken
sadie is big smooth and dr. Britt Baker
TV and dr. Britvic are getting the
hero's welcome here from the Chicago
faithfuls now Penelope Ford comes off
that pop crashing on to NYLO Rose while
the remaining competitors are making
their way to the ring now Penelope Ford
back handspring back elbow my little
Bros looked a little bit rattled as
Penelope floored seeing her first
in-ring action here in all elite
wrestling we saw her at double or
nothing she came out with Joey janela
but this is what's going to be this
situation for Penelope Fort McHenry
taking a big swole
Oh Oh Britt Baker
Brett Baker given that uh that dr. Brook
Baker DMD given a dental health
evaluation Shah's McKenzie and now state
he gives in the corner with nylon rows
running knee strike there from shots
McKenzie center of the Ring I feel like
every time you talk about Britt Baker
there's always a good
- preference to bring up there has to be
she practiced a doctor there medical
dentistry now shaza McKenzie climbing up
the Rope superburger trying to force her
to the outside but Sheldon may be a
little too eager Oh shovel Mackenzie get
stuff to the outside such a shame
therefore shaza McKenzie [ __ ] the show
must go on it will not be a Shazz tastic
evening for shaza then Britt Baker right
to work immediately I'm the biggest
threat in that ring it's going to be
nyla Rose who once again manages the
manhandle not one with a chokeslam
Excalibur double chokeslam from nyla
roast showing off her strength with big
swole coming in from behind you'll see
who's the biggest swole in this match
maybe the speed and that's what she's
doing
powerhouse kick duck oh oh oh cracks
with a headbutt Casa Dora
[Applause]
lanten Nilo roast face-first center of
the Ring
Oh Savior you could be fast in that ring
nyla will punish you for butts big slow
recognizing the opportunity at hand but
nyla Rose immediately grabbing her
fireman's carry good fireman's carry big
swell fighting from the outside she is
in a dangerous position grabbing a
guillotine nyla Rose guillotine now
swallow
creating some distance charging into
nyla Rose now the Rose caches are just
blends over there or Nagi on the ring
apron and swole just falsely outside
Seoul but there from today I'll be
forward is the next suit about the end
of the ring now that before it gets wet
luck charm is too much black spinel
before to the back of our head when we
saw the countdown but the next group
taking their time should be up in a
little bit meanwhile in the ring Bella
before bright over like a sack of
potatoes just planted on the turnbuckle
approaching me Nate - Neal - would even
loose priestly
[Applause]
Rick Baker immediately gone after be
priestly just laying its shots on the
rim this is the fallout from fight for
the Fallen in Jacksonville just a few
weeks ago and I was gonna say business
is about to pick up like our friend good
old JR says but it seems like this
already picked up yeah she's looking to
cash in right away and then now ivelisse
and city gives you the ring Oh two-nil
Dashwood actually believes across the
chaulk hilarious estate he gives a lot
of threats in that ring excalibur
ivelisse such a veteran in this business
and then - Neal - would a fantastic
wrestler in her own right Sadie Gibbs
look for her to make some noise say it's
a Ivelisse yeah a relative newcomer but
even least with the experienced edge but
- Neal - was showing her experienced
edge as he police was playing to the
crowd now - nil don't wander hook a plug
ah-ha-ho just butterfly suplex in -
Sadie Gibson now - now the chase tops
are now right to the corner you got two
people stacked together that is gonna
hurt but here we go
awesome Kong and she's getting
directions going on Brandi Road a look
at this duo that just entered the ring I
wonder if it's a coincidence that brandi
roads and awesome Kong had the same suit
there can be only one Joker but brandy
Rhodes has proven time after time that
she relies on awesome Kong to be her
muscle flying right in the middle of the
ring was Ivelisse there now brandy going
for Sadie bride into the arms of Awesome
Kong good dropkick their objections back
o Kong take Stella brandy not sure if
that was intentional or not I'm maybe uh
maybe also Kong is thinking she might
need to deserve a raise Nayla rose
she was on the outside but was on the
outside underneath the bottom rope so
she was not officially eliminated has
now said he gives
Ivelisse and Tennille - what about Oh
Brandi with her back turns and awesome
tongue is occupied with three other
women in that ring so this is nyla Rose
having her way and this the chief brandi
officer here
and this is the opportunity for nyla
Rose to get some measure of revenge for
Brandi interjecting awesome Kong and her
match at double or nothing
payback is a dish best served cold nyla
looking to give her a frozen one there
but breathing asunder big stunner on
nyla rose and awesome Kong has created
some distance for herself she dumps two
nila Dashwood after the ring apron
Ivelisse on the shoulders off the put o
city Gibbs
he's a pair of boots - no - would taken
off the edge all the Lorcan old man
right to the face and awesome Kong is
doing the job for brandy that's what
exactly what she was hired for that
spinning backfist that working knocking
Ivelisse off the apron and off kong
looking up the ramp as the hearts are
making their way into the casino battle
royale a person airing next alley
alakazoo Savoy till Piper D me
[Applause]
Shaz making her appearance her presence
felt here in Chicago Illinois crowd on
their feet for jazz the veteran making
her way to the ring now but while that
was going on we have to acknowledge the
fact that alley sheep be lined it
straight for brandy giving her no moment
to breathe they're just like we saw
brick Baker attack could be Priestley
earlier on alley
another wronged party by brandy Rhodes
brandy was crying those crocodile tears
saying she needed to be her demons
wouldn't really look at this to square
off in the center of the ring Nicole
Savoy that's good Nicole Savoy just got
bunk up the top of the head by awesome
Kong Kong sensor to the Rope they call
talk face so aceite take advantage of
the opportunity that was presented to
her rather do that and go right into the
arms of Awesome Kong not what you want
to happen in this casino Battle Royale
ODB jazz beat priestly in Brit Baker was
fighting on the outside and now Nicole
Savoy Wan brick Baker into the ring
ODB he's got the flask out she had to
play Mirage hillclimber with a poke in
the eye and now the sleeper ship like
the sleeper whole center of the ring
seal pie for the daughter of the
legendary Roddy Piper using his patented
poke in the eye technique but
unfortunately awesome Kong again not
having an eye that neither roses the
handful of hair on be priests her excuse
me on Nicole Savoy yeah so voice sent to
the outside teal Piper to the outside by
awesome car now Kong and a little Rose
meeting I - I sent her up to a ring heel
was thrown through the middle rope by
the way so she still in this matchup now
we're finally gonna get the lock up that
were looking for but here comes jazz
jazz licensor like a hot knife through
butter
oh man what a faceoff of for the
heaviest hitters and women professional
wrestling crowd on their feet for ODB
here but there are so many women in this
matchup that have the capability of
going huge when they need to and here
comes our final player in this one the
Joker who's it going to be tough to the
outside and now jazz with the crucifix
on either rose ODB
eliminating jazz but epitome of the rap
and ladies and gentlemen eat sugar
Mercedes Martinez ovation for Mercedes
Martinez drug the Joker card the last
woman to enter the casino battle royale
with a distinct advantage Oh Brandi gets
tossed out
[Applause]
Mercedes Martinez Hester's the ring le
makes a beeline for her Mercedes fine
Buster Rick Baker throws the line hearse
up over the top just dumps her release
Northern Lights now Sadie gasps turns it
in as well you can have some of it as
well
Sherman suplex for Sadie's Gibbs
Mercedes Martinez cutting a path the
priest-king shoulder capture no nice
European uppercut there by Mercedes
Martinez going in for it now
Bree pick pre-sleep does recognize
hollow Mercedes rolls through huge curb
stomp but Nylund Rose waiting in the
wings with a fireman's carry
Mercedes trying to flight free
Bali's Martinez wanna start here for her
in the women's casino Battle Royale
massive muscle cerritos suplex now Ali
blames her right elbow to three
consecutive elbows shots up on the
shoulders of Ali
we're city's Martinez Valley driver with
Brandi runs eliminated from this match
Ali now only has to focus on that
opportunity for the aew Women's World
Championship title but can we
acknowledge the fact that nyla Rose came
out first and is still in this one still
going and even though right now she is
not in this action she is still a threat
to every person in that ring very much
so
Ali went for the monkey flip in the
corner Mercedes placing around the top
rope this is a dangerous spot for these
women to be fighting Ali Oh held on hold
on her feet on the apron still fighting
off attackers coming from all angles yes
nyla
jumps Ali to the floor ending her
evening now Sadie Gibbs smartboard
lariat takes on neither rose
[Applause]
Sadie gives up to her feet as we have
the purchase information for all out
coming up at the top of the hour
providers we are live the VR live app
ITV box office in the UK and Ireland and
fun TV internationally as Sadie Gibbs
has her fellow countrywoman or adopted
country would be Priestley up on her
shoulders now Sadie
yes I've got real oppressive be
over-the-top no be avoided Sadie that
gives the cat not be dumped to the
outside and be priestly after that
explosive debut at fight for the fallen
that Brit Baker talked to Rick Baker's
certainly not forgotten about she's
looking to keep the momentum going here
when Mercedes Martinez looking to
eliminate Brett Rick fights her way back
to the center Mercedes lazy and elbow
shot Hades has that slight his sling
blade Mercedes has that slight advantage
she came out last she drew the Joker
card so she's nearly she's not nearly as
exhausted as these other women here
bonala Rose is going to go in for the
attack now be Priestley off of the road
tries to hit it but neither oh oh no
that is hands on that's the strength of
benefit oh no oh man Oh shot to the knee
maybe even the shin setting up for the
running knee strike from Mercedes
Martinez great inadvertent teamwork
there by Brit and Mercedes that's what
it's gonna take to eliminate nyla rose
from this competition
she is the threat I'll keep on saying it
everyone needs to look out please
Priestley try to go for Mercedes and
it's now going for brick Baker she she
saved nyla rose in an effort to
eliminate the other two competitors was
that even a wise player who's stupid
not good Gary Martinez gets 11 I did not
see that one coming at all Mercedes
Martinez drew the Joker card she had
that advantage but in the ring getting
to her feet the person who came out
first the woman who came out here first
and their first group nyla Rose going up
against brick Baker and of course be
Priestley it's the age-old question of
professional wrestling will these rivals
will be Priestley and brick Baker able
to cook be able to coexist will they be
able to put their differences aside to
eliminate nyla Rose they're gonna batter
they there they go the opportunity to
become the first eighteen champion is on
the line super tech rights and now the
Rosa's dome another knee right to the
face here's the opportunity that they
were looking for nyla Rose son over the
top she has clawed feet that knock
for what are they going to do to get rid
of her
now the Rose unbelievable she went for
the car filled it right on the apron
tremendously tremendously dangerous move
for now the rose had they been it had
rip and beeban a step faster their
momentum when he carried her off but all
the splash in the corner now nyla Rose
has him right where she wants him turned
her back on be priestly but able to just
kick her off and now Oh brick Baker pop
up her head but she is all that dead
weight that's what beep recently is so
now brick breaker needs to make a
decision does she go after nyla Rose
who's getting up she's gonna have the
leverage there as well nyla Rose gonna
be in a tough spot but she still has
that strength that power to be able to
knock Britt away from her those rising
elbows and forearms strikes off the
middle bringing nyla in but doing damage
in the process these women what a
display here to start things off her the
all-out buying
the opportunity to compete for the
first-ever AED women can be a strike
what a huge opportunity that will be
when these one of these women go to
Washington DC be priestly what agility
as she climbed to the top roof writ able
to fight her off or headbutt catching
Britain right on the nose being
Priestley's out be Priestley's out
that's going to leave our final two
women standing great Baker and Nilo
Romans are you driving only be priestly
class of the casino alone that native
beast
nyah nyah Rose going bell-to-bell
so impressive to Wynn casino qualifying
to punch her ticket for Washington
see from home
once you pay
car seat up which will take place later
on tonight the winners that match will
face back
to be crowned the first-ever aew women's
world champion it's been a rough start
here for nyla Rose mean om - she fell at
double or nothing she also lost at
fighter fest but now finally she's gonna
get the opportunity and here's the thing
if you're Rio or her carshena then there
is a thread and there is what it's all
about right there the aew women's
championship that rose gold
jewel-encrusted felt hand-picked by the
CBO randy rhoads herself and nylon
laser-focused on that belt on that title
on the opportunity to make history in
Washington DC on